يمكن برمجة الأقراص التي تباع بالتجزئة لأقل من
20 لاعبًا ، والتي تتراوح تكلفتها بين 300 إلى أكثر من
ألف مشغل ،
لمنح المستمع التحكم في ترتيب
التحديدات ، حيث توجد نسخة محمولة في
الطريق ، كما هو الحال بالنسبة لإصدار سيارتك
، لا يحتوي القرص المضغوط على أي أخاديد
والصينية الدوارة ليست قرصًا دوارًا ، ولكن يتم تسجيل
مشغل بشعاع ليزر بدلاً من
إبرة
موسيقية عليه من خلال
عملية كمبيوتر رقمية تحول
الملاحظات إلى أرقام ، حيث يقرأ الليزر
الأرقام ويترجمها مرة أخرى إلى
موسيقى واضحة وضوح الشمس مهندس الصوت فان
ويبستر  أعجب
بالسحر الفني للقرص الجديد ، لكنه يقول إن
ملاءمته هي ما سيثير إعجاب
الجمهور ، فهو غير قابل للتدمير تقريبًا
من حيث التآكل العادي ، ويمكن تنظيفه
بسهولة بقطعة قماش ناعمة
، ولا يخضع للنقرات الخدوش المنبثقة
أو أنواع أخرى من الأسطح
ضوضاء مضغوطة وسهلة التعامل مع الأقراص
بالتجزئة بأقل من 20 دولارًا ، تكلفة المشغلات
من 300 إلى أكثر من ألف
يمكن برمجتها على
يتحكم المستمع في ترتيب
التحديدات ، نسخة محمولة في
الطريق ، كما هو الحال مع نسخة لسيارتك ،
يقول فان ويبستر إن القرص المضغوط أو القرص المضغوط
سيجعل قريباً
ثانية من lp قديمة في طريقها 45 ثانية لجميع الأغراض العملية.
ثمان خراطيش مسار في
طريقها ، فقد حان الوقت لكي يتحرك قرص الفينيل
في طريقه ،
وتم بيع ثمانمائة ألف من الأقراص الجديدة في
عام 1983 ، ومن المتوقع بيع خمسة ملايين أخرى
هذا العام ، وكلها
أخبار جيدة لمطوري  يقول قرص هانز
النقرس إن شركة فيليبس قامت
باستثمار كبير في النظام
بشكل
هائل وأعتقد أن
فيليبس
ربما أنفق ربما ثلاثة
وأربعمائة مليون دولار في السبعينيات
في
البحث عن نظام القرص الضوئي هذا
، كما أنفقت الشركة مائة
مليون دولار لكل منها
مصنعان للتصنيع مثل أحدهما في
terre haute indiana لن
يؤتي الاستثمار ثماره إلا إذا استمر اهتمام المستهلك
بالقرص المضغوط في النمو وصناعة الموسيقى  جرب
المحللون يقولون إنه في الواقع
يتوقعون أنه في غضون 10 سنوات
سيتم العثور على مشغلات قياسية تقليدية
فقط في المتاحف
ساندي كينيون.